[VIDEO GAME BEEPING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Cloud Bigtable
is Google's NoSQL big data
database service.
It's the same database that
powers many core Google
services, including Search,
Analytics, Maps, and Gmail.
Bigtable is designed to
handle massive workloads
at consistent low latency
and high throughput,
so it's a great choice for
both operational and analytical
applications, including
IoT, user analytics,
and financial data analysis.
In this lab, you'll learn
how to use the CBT command
line to create and connect
to a Cloud Bigtable instance,
perform basic
administrative tasks,
and read and write
data in a table.
We've added some
links below so you
can learn more about
Cloud Bigtable,
and see how it can help you
handle massive workloads
quickly and seamlessly.
This self-paced lab is
part of the Baseline--
Data, ML, and AI
quest on Quiklabs.
A quest is a series of related
labs that form a learning path.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
Next up, Cloud
Natural Language API--
Qwik Start.
You'll be using a student GCP
account to work on these labs,
but if you're ready to
get your own GCP account,
here's $300 to get you started.